[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be counting down the top 10
strongest students in the world of boku
no hero including students from
different classes and grades in UA and
also students from other hero academies
we will be focusing on combat capability
in particular now different quirks have
different strengths and weaknesses and
some of these students have never fought
against each other in a serious capacity
but I will use what we know about each
student and their quirks thus far
including the feats that they were able
to achieve in the story I will be going
by how strong each character is at their
peak and not just how strong their quirk
is on its own before we get started I
want to give a quick shout out to the my
hero academia amino app I've been using
amino for over a year now because amino
has a ton of interesting communities
that offer a great way to interact with
thousands of other fans I've been a
member of the MHA amino for a long time
it's such a fun and interactive place to
be and I love checking out fan art
sharing my content and getting feedback
from fellow fans and nowadays with all
the season 3 hype i often see well over
1,000 people online at the same time we
have our own anime opera profilin
because we have so many ideas for future
MHA videos I created a poll where you
guys can vote for which video you want
to see next the poll will be up for a
limited time only so once you get the
app just look for anime uproar and
follow us like right now let's do it you
can download the app it's totally free
for iPhone or Android just check the
link in the description and a huge thank
you to amino for supporting anime uproar
and making it possible for us to keep
making more content quick warning that
this video will contain manga spoilers
as some of the students in the top 10
have not yet been introduced in the
anime I'll do my best to explain my
logic for how I rank them in the video
but this is not an exact science so if
you disagree with anything feel free to
give me your arguments down in the
comments oh and if you enjoyed the boku
no hero content on this channel and you
want to see more you can let me know by
leaving a like and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
unite it
states of smash that notification bell
at number 10 we have a judo Kirishima
from class 1a the name of his quirk is
hardening and it essentially allows KD
Shima to harden and sharpen any part of
his body using his work also gives Katie
Shima extra physical strength and the
ability to withstand immensely powerful
attacks including explosions
Kirishima cannot stay in his hardened
mode forever and if he takes enough
damage he will revert back to normal but
although he wouldn't have made this list
earlier on in the story as of right now
Kitty Shima has made a lot of progress
both with his quirk and with his overall
training after mastering his super move
read riot unbreakable Kenisha
gains the ability to withstand
practically any attack without taking on
damage and during the internship arc he
is able to face off against extremely
strong and experienced Yakuza members
roppa and Tang guy and eventually
Kirishima emerges victorious in this
battle with the help of pro hero fat gum
for this reason I feel that Kirishima
deserves to be in the top 10 strongest
students at this point in the story at
number 9 we have Yosh endo a second-year
student at katsu bhutesu hero Academy
the name of his quirk is vibrate and it
enables him to send powerful vibrations
through anything he touches during the
provisional hero license exam Shindo
demonstrates the ability to create a
massive earthquake by touching the
ground and this earthquake completely
reshaped the entire battlefield he can
control the speed and intensity of the
vibrations that he creates so he can
choose to create a violent earthquake or
just a slight tremor
Shindo is also shown to be very
strategic and part of the reason why he
reshapes the battlefield is to split up
the you a student so they can't keep
working together
Shindo squirt does have a drawback which
is that his body will feel aftershocks
after he uses it and if he uses too much
power he could damage his body however
having to constantly deal with
aftershocks has actually made him more
resistant to attacks that caused
vibrations and tremors including gang
orcas supersonic waves the reason that
Shindo doesn't rank even higher on this
list is the fact that the drop
Java squirt could prove to be a big
problem in longer battles and also
because we haven't seen that much of him
yet but I definitely think that he
deserves to be at number nine at number
8 we have Neji dejado a third-year
student at UA and one of the members of
the big three major s quark enables her
to turn her own life energy into
shockwaves that she can then use against
her opponents she can also use the
shockwaves to move around quickly and
jump through the air as if she were
flying solar quark is obviously both
very strong and useful and as an
outstanding student Nigeria has been
able to harness her quirks potential in
order to become one of the top three
heroes and training at UA I believe that
ninja has definitely earned her place as
one of the top 10 strongest students but
the reason that she doesn't rank even
higher on this list is that her quirk
depends on Nigeria using up her own
energy or stamina so the amount of power
that she can generate at any given time
is limited and if she exceeds this limit
Nigeria will collapse from fatigue Abbe
number seven we have class 1a student
kotsky Baku
and yes I know what the Bakugan boys
like my good buddy Jordan the anime dude
are thinking Baku go is only at number
seven but he's the greatest of all time
he's the goat Baku goat man I bet that
this is his actual face right now but
before you freak out hear me out if you
don't end up agreeing with my reasoning
by all means give me your reasoning down
in the comments oh and feel free to
check out the anime dudes channel linked
in the description
Baku goal is definitely one of the
strongest students in class 1a and his
quark explosion allows him to generate
sweat that is similar in its chemical
makeup to nitroglycerin on explosive
liquid which enables Baku go to generate
powerful explosions from his hands Baku
Co uses grenadiers bracers the things on
his hands that look like giant hand
grenades in order to maximize the
effectiveness of his quark the bracers
allow him to store sweat and make his
blasts more powerful while also
protecting him from hurting himself
while using the quark explosion is a
very versatile ability and it can be
used to launch a single piercing blast
or
rapid-fire barrage of smaller blasts
Bakugan also uses the explosions to move
faster and to propel himself through the
air and because he is very intelligent
and strategic in battle Baku go is able
to use his quirk to great effect in any
combat situation however Baku goal can
also be too brash and rush into battle
before properly assessing the situation
on top of that his quirk does have
certain limitations like being more
difficult to use and cold weather
because it requires sweat and overuse of
the quirk will also put a strain on the
user's body and while Baku has
definitely shown himself to be a very
strong fighter throughout the series
including when he won the entire sports
festival tournament Baku goes brashness
and temper have also proven to be a
clear disadvantage including during the
provisional hero license exam for this
reason I feel that the students that are
still to come on this list have shown
themselves to be even more effective
fighters than Baku go at number 6 we
have Seiji Sakura a 2nd year student
from the sheikah zoo hero Academy his
clerk called meatball allows Seiji to
control and alter human flesh if he
makes contact with the bodies of his
rivals Seiji can turn them into
motionless balls of meat he can also
break off parts of his own flesh and
control them separately from his body so
he can basically use a part of his flesh
to sneak up on an opponent from behind
without the opponent even realizing
what's happening before being turned
into a helpless meatball
during the hero license exam ark we see
Seiji use his quirk to take out between
15 and 20 different students at the same
time including Bakugan himself
Seiji is ultimately defeated because
community is able to use an assist from
Baku go to damage Seiji enough so that
his quirt would wear off and this is the
only known weakness that sage he has his
quirk wears off if he suffers enough
damage but the fact that sage he took
down between 15 and 20 opponents on his
own including Bakugan before finally
being defeated demonstrates the
incredible strength of Seiji and his
weird meat-processing quirk Seiji is
definitely not perfect and Baku and
think he did man
to outwit him together but he still
earned his place at number 6 on our list
at number 5 Inasa yashi a first-year
student from the sheikah Zoo hero
Academy in NASA has a wind-based quirk
which enables him to create and control
wind gusts and he has demonstrated a
great deal of precision with his power
he can use the wind to create powerful
offensive attacks like tornadoes and
thanks to some special customizations on
his suit he can also use his wind quirk
to propel himself forward and to make
himself fly his quirk is so strong that
during the first round of the
provisional hero license exam he was
able to eliminate 120 rival students at
once which speaks to his incredible
power in the past Inasa actually took
part in the UA entrance exam with
Todoroki and deku and even though he
performed really well and finished the
exam just ahead of Todoroki he decided
to decline the offer of admission and to
go to sheikah too high instead due to
the insane power of his quirk and due to
the fact that he worked hard to be able
to control it with great skill and
precision in esse lands at number 5 on
our list at number 4 class 1 a student
short taught Todoroki as a result of his
quirk half cold half hot Todoroki can
generate powerful flames from the left
side of the body and from the right side
of his body he is able to generate ice
and use it to freeze objects and people
around him he can even create giant
walls of ice and freeze entire buildings
in the beginning of the story Shoto only
uses the ice side of his quirk refusing
to use the fire side because of his
hatred for his father and ever as a
result he lost to buck go in the finals
of the Sports Festival but since then
Shoto has come to terms with using the
hot side of his quark and he has come a
long way in mastering both sides and
using them effectively in combination
with each other the one drawback of his
quark is that if he uses either side too
much Todoroki can suffer physical
consequences either frostbite from his
cold side or potentially dehydration and
exhaustion from his hot side however if
he uses both sides of his quark in a
complimentary way he can largely
counterbalance the negative effects
one side or the other because of the
open nature of his quark because he is
an extremely gifted and skillful fighter
and because he is continuing to improve
and develop as the story progresses
Todoroki lands at number four on our
list and number three we have another
class 1a student azúcar midoriya aka
Deku this student and his quark need no
introduction but to be brief Deku is the
9th and current user of one for all a
quark that is the synthesis of two
previously separate quirks a quirk that
stockpiles power and a quirk that allows
quirks to be willingly transferred from
one person to another one for all gives
its users superhuman strength reflexes
stamina agility and speed and one for
all also has some additional mysterious
powers that we are not fully informed
about such as the ability to somehow
snap deku out of Shin Zoe's mind-control
quark during the sports festival now I
can already hear some people saying bro
my boy Deku should be number one and
other people saying Deku is way too
overrated he shouldn't be this high on
the list but in this case the feats
speak for themselves and whether we like
it or not
Deku was able to defeat the extremely
powerful and experienced villain
muscular on his own he was also able to
defeat the gentle criminal on his own
even though gentle was shown taking out
multiple pro heroes by himself and dec
who beat gentle even while he was
getting help from la bravas quark deck
who was also the one who finally
defeated fused overhall albeit with
aries help no other student that we
talked about so far has achieved
comparable feat so even if you think
that it is problematic for a first-year
student to be so strong already you will
have to take that up with horikoshi not
with me at number 2 we have Tamaki
ammaji ki another member of the u-ace
big three Tamaki ammaji Keys hero name
is Sun eater and his quirk manifest
allows its user to transform his body in
a unique way his body can manifest the
properties of the things he eats such as
turning his fingers into tentacles after
eating octopus along with that
Tamaki can manifest the properties of
multiple different substances at the
same time and combined them on his body
so for
example of heeds both octopus and crab
he can manifest a claw and tentacles on
his hand at the same time even if he
consumes objects that are not
necessarily food such as a small piece
of crystal he can then manifest hardened
crystals on his body the ability to
manifest the properties of the things he
consumes only lasts for as long as he
has the objects in his digestive system
so Tamaki tries to eat a wide variety of
different useful foods every day in
order to always be ready in case he
needs to use his quirk Tamaki was able
to defeat multiple seasoned villains at
the same time by himself we basically
see and take out three of overhall
strong and experienced henchmen on his
own and because of his extensive
training and experience with an already
awesome and versatile quirk Tamaki lands
at number two on our list before we get
to the number one strongest dude and I
want to talk about some honorable
mentions we have students like Takuya me
and community who have extremely strong
quirks but haven't mastered them fully
yet and still lose control sometimes so
that is why they are not on this list at
this time but this could change in the
future remember that this list is about
the strength of the character not the
quirk itself we also have sheikah to
high school students kami and Mora who
have strong quirks and look like future
contenders for the top ten but we just
haven't seen them in action often enough
to say for sure especially when it comes
to the real kami for fans of class 1b I
think Nate Oh Kendall Ibarra tattoo
Tetsu and a few others have great
potential but we need to see them do
more in the story and finally characters
like Momo and he Toshi Xin so have
awesome quirks that could propel them to
the top but so far they just haven't
shown as much as the ten students on
this list in terms of raw fighting
ability in particular don't forget that
this list is primarily about combat
skills and at number one media toccata
the final member of the u.s. big three
medial aka LM million is perhaps the
single hardest working and most
dedicated student of all even though his
quirk is extremely hard to use Media
underwent painstaking training in order
to master it the name of his quirk is
permeation and it allows its users body
or specific parts of his body to pass
through anything that is either solid
or liquid including walls floors and
ceilings although for the time he is
permeable he cannot use his senses and
so he cannot see or hear anything me do
is also able to effectively teleport
from one place to another using his
quirk if he turns his quirk off while
passing to an object his body will be
quickly shot out of the object in a way
that makes it appear that he is
teleporting from one place to another
through training myrio is able to
control the direction of the ejections
allowing him to rapidly appear exactly
where he wants to be in terms of feats
meteo is capable of defeating all of
class 1a by himself in a very short
period of time which alone should tell
you how insanely strong this guy is he
is also able to get the better of
overhaul and chrono stasis until they
use Aries safety as a way to catch him
off-guard and hit him with the perk
destroying bullet but nevertheless when
he has the full use of his quirk me do
is without a doubt the strongest student
in boku no hero and that's it for the
list if you guys enjoyed this video I
want to see more you can let me know by
leaving a like if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
united states of smash that notification
bell be sure to leave your feedback in
the comments and you can also hit us up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
as always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]